[Musique]
chez les médecins documentaires
exclusifs réalisés par Xavier Deleu et
Julie Pichot une enquête qui donne vous
venez de le voir non seulement la parole
aux victimes mais suis également leur
long combat pour faire condamner leurs
agresseurs en blouse blanche peut-on
tenter d'évaluer l'ampleur de ces
violences sexuelles exercées sur des
patientes dans le huis clos des cabinets
médicaux comment y mettre un terme face
au mur du silence longtemps préserver
notamment par l'Ordre des médecins nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau de débat
doc avec vous pour commencer Xavier
Deleu bienvenue à vous vous êtes
réalisateur avec une filmographie très
dense et vous avez donc consigné ce
documentaire aux côtés de la journaliste
Julie Pichot Anne bodono et Taven d'où
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste nous
vous avons découvert dans ce film dans
cette enquête alors que vous étiez
adolescente vous avez été victime de
violences sexuelles de la part de votre
psychiatre un délit impunié à ce jour et
vous faites aujourd'hui partie de ces
femmes qui entendent plus que jamais
alerter l'opinion publique sur le tabou
que constitue encore les agresseurs les
agressions de sexuel en blouse blanche
Muriel Salmona est également avec nous
bienvenue vous êtes psychiatre
fondatrice et présidente de
l'association mémoire traumatique et
victimologique je vous remercie d'être à
nouveau avec nous sur ce plateau de de
débat doc lorsqu’il est question de ces
questions vous êtes par ailleurs
l'auteur de ce livre c'est un livre
référence d'ailleurs le Livre noir des
violences sexuelles c'est la troisième
édition de ce livre qu'on nous vous
présentons en même temps que je vous
présente sur ce plateau je me tourne
tout de suite vers vous vous êtes donc
le corréalisateur de ce film les
premières images de cette enquête ont
été tournées il y a 10 ans mais est-ce
que ça ne veut pas dire que c'est un
sujet effectivement tabou et un sujet
dont personne ne voulait vraiment
entendre parler au moment où vous avez
commencé à entreprendre cette enquête
c'est exactement ça enfin il y a eu
c'était bien avant Mitou puisque les
premières images date de décembre
2011 lorsque je filme Jacky en Corse et
en fait j'imaginais pas à l'époque que
ça prendrait autant de temps alors
j'avais évidemment
envie de accompagner ce qui semblait
pouvoir être un long combat judiciaire
on sait que ça prend du temps mais
jamais j'aurais imaginé que finalement
pendant toutes ces années je dirais 2013
14 15 16 la plupart des chaînes de
télévision auxquelles je proposais le
sujet se désintéressait absolument de
cette thématique c'est un sujet que vous
avez profité à d'autres chaînes dont
elles n'ont pas voulu dont elles n'ont
pas vouloir intéressez pas ça les
intéressait pas le titre de travail à
l'époque c'était c'était pourtant
l'emprise alors dans les premières
années 2011-2012 2013 et je me souviens
en avoir parlé avec Salmona à l'époque
l'emprise était un terme qu'on
connaissait pas puis après il est devenu
trop à la mode et puis entre deux
d'autres chaînes m'ont dit
écoute Xavier arrête avec cette
proposition de sujet que tu nous fais
sans arrêt on touchera pas au médecin
oui c'est quelque chose d'extrêmement
violent je vois pas pourquoi il
s'agissait pas de toucher à tous les
médecins il s'agissait pas de d'attaquer
toute une corporation simplement à
l'intérieur de cette corporation il y a
des gens qui profitent d'un système
c'est vrai que vous avez utilisé le
terme de huis clos médical c'est ça en
fait il y a chaque semaine je sais pas
peut-être un million de rendez-vous
médicaux et à l'intérieur de ce
face-à-face il se passe parfois des
choses donc je ne comprends pas pourquoi
on refuserait d'en parler cette enquête
est-ce qu'elle vous a permis un temps
soit peu d'estimer l'ampleur du
phénomène que vous décrivez dans ce film
autrement dit les violences sexuelles
par les médecins dans ces fameux
cabinets médicaux à huis clos
sincèrement non je crois que l'ampleur
on la connaît pas encore en tout cas moi
je suis pas capable de la connaître que
je sais c'est que
dans les années 2012 13 suivant Jacky
puis d'autres personnes je me suis
aperçu que des victimes sur internet sur
facebook partager ce qui leur était
arrivé et je me suis aussi aperçu que
dans l'essentiel des cas il y avait pas
de plaintes en fait donc c'est compliqué
après une chose m'a surpris c'est vrai
que en faisant cette revue de presse au
départ mais c'est aperçu qu'on parlait
beaucoup de psychiatre on parlait
beaucoup de
gynécologue et
en fait c'est ça n'était pas un choix en
fait à priori comme ça de Monsieur pas
dit enfin si l'agresseur avait été un
généraliste ma foi j'aurais suivi de la
même manière la même personne le
collectif émises contre le viol vous
savez depuis les années 80 reçoit des
des tas d'appels et ce sont des dizaines
d'appels ou des centaines d'appels qui
concernent des médecins donc elles ont
fait une sorte de de statistique si vous
voulez de elles se sont aperçu qu'en
vérité ça concerne tous les corps de
métiers de médecins c'est du médecin du
travail le médecin du sport
l'anesthésiste le radiologue voilà mais
il se trouve qu'à un tiers de
psychiatres et aussi beaucoup de
gynécologues et moi ce tiers de
psychiatre de psychiatre et beaucoup de
gynécologues voilà le de psychiatre m'a
intéressé moi à l'origine qui ne
connaissait pas plus ce sujet si vous
voulez il y a 10 ans que nos
téléspectateurs aujourd'hui si vous
voulez mais moi ce qui m'intéressait
c'est de me dire qu'avec le psychiatre
on avait quelqu'un qui n'a pas
naturellement axé au corps de ses
patients de ses patients donc on voyait
en tout cas pour si l'idée c'était aussi
de rappeler ce que c'est qu'un viol on
voit que c'est pas nécessairement
avec enfin
favoriser par l'accès au corps et en
plus c'est aussi enfin le psychiatre
quelqu'un qui a plutôt normalement c'est
ça son métier d'accès à la psyché donc
finalement ça me permettait même à moi
de comprendre ce que c'était qu'un viol
c'est-à-dire ce que c'était que
l'emprise c'est-à-dire ce que c'était
que la de prendre en otage quelqu'un
pour en arriver à à l'agression sexuelle
justement c'est un psychiatre dont vous
avez été victime violence sexuelle alors
que vous étiez mineur un psychiatre que
vous connaissiez depuis un peu plus de
deux ans vous êtes retourné voir après
la mort on l'a appris dans ce film de
votre le suicide de votre frère aîné
et c'est lui donc qui commettra ce
violence sexuelle auprès de vous ce
qu'on n'a pas dans ce documentaire
est-ce que peut-être important de
comprendre c'est que après vous avez
cherché j'imagine en parler de cette
agression et de ses violences sexuelles
subit dans ce cabinet de ce psychiatre
auprès de vos proches auprès peut-être
d'autres thérapeutes
comment les choses se sont passées après
c'était quelques années plus tard en
fait j'avais à peu près 24 ou 25 ans
quand j'ai essayé d'en parler
j'ai essayé d'en parler à deux personnes
de mon entourage mais de manière très
allusive que qui n'était pas forcément
très compréhensible pour des gens un peu
familiarisés du sujet puis j'ai
également tenter d'alerter deux médecins
un médecin généraliste et une psychiatre
que je suis allée revoir en prenant
beaucoup sur moi parce que c'est très
difficile de faire confiance ensuite à
nouveau un professionnel de santé et
donc du coup ça retarde d'autant la
dénonciation aussi les faits puisque
c'est quand même un professionnel vers
lequel on a tendance à se tourner le
médecin pour confier ce genre de choses
donc je suis allée voir ces personnes et
donc quelques années plus tard quand
j'ai enfin fait la démarche avec le
Conseil de l'Ordre le généraliste m'a
dit vous avez été la seule à me le dire
donc bien sûr j'ai continué à envoyer
des gens chez lui quand elle a
psychiatre elle m'a dit à ce moment-là
j'attendais que vous m'en disiez plus
alors que j'ai essayé de j'ai essayé de
venir sur le sujet en plus comme elle
était dans la même ville que la personne
que j'ai dénoncé j'étais un peu mal à
l'aise je ne savais pas du tout comment
elle pouvait réagir et donc comme elle
semblait pas vouloir aborder le sujet
moi j'ai mis pendant quelques années mon
mouchoir dessus de sorte que la
prescription pénale a été acquise
puisque à l'époque c'était 10 ans
c'était 10 ans pour pour oui les 10 ans
après la majorité à l'époque où
maintenant il y a 30 ans pour les viols
maintenant mais donc
du coup je suis restée je suis restée
comme ça et quand j'ai voulu le dire en
fait c'était c'était trop tard
pénalement mais j'ai voulu quand même le
signaler au procureur de la République
parce que je me disais il y a forcément
enfin pour moi c'était évident que
c'était quelqu'un qui faisait ça de
manière récurrente donc je m'inquiétais
beaucoup pour les autres personnes et
c'était un point que je portais donc je
j'ai voulu j'ai voulu faire un
signalement pour qu'il y ait en quête
alors l'enquête a été à l'époque il
s'est pas des enquêtes très poussées
dans ces cas-là était prescrit l'enquête
s'est bornée a interrogé cette personne
et puis m'interroger moi et puis après
ça a été classé sans suite pour
prescription
auprès de l'Ordre des médecins mais ça
on va reparler oui un tout petit peu
plus tard lorsqu'on parle de ces
violences sexuelles exercées par des
médecins
en quoi est-ce qu'elles sont
radicalement différentes ces violences
sexuelles d'autres formes de violences
sexuelles on parle vraiment d'un sujet
de tabou oui et puis on parle de
situation qui s'exercent dans dans un
contexte là de grandes vulnérabilité
c'est-à-dire que avec une position de
domination et d'autorité d'un côté du
médecin et vulnérabilité des patients
qui sont souvent mineurs en plus il faut
le rappeler c'est la grande majorité des
victimes de violences sexuelles sont
mineures et qui sont inquiète qui sont
malades et qui vont donner toutes leurs
confiance
à un professionnel un peu comme dans une
famille en quelque sorte où on a
confiance dans les personnes qui
prennent soin de nous et du coup il y a
la en fait la sidération et la surprise
et d'autres le trauma est d'autant plus
grand parce que c'est impensable enfin
je veux dire c'est
les personnes ne peuvent pas du tout se
protéger a priori d'une attaque dans ce
contexte là donc ça met les personnes
dans une dans une situation des derniers
endroits où on peut supposer qu'on va
être victime voilà et c'est pour ça
d'ailleurs qu'il y a un tabou parce que
du coup c'est pas pensable et puis il y
a toujours aussi ces stéréotypes qui
font que on pense que c'est lié à du
désert sexuel à une interaction avec une
personne alors que les violences
sexuelles c'est une position de
domination c'est une position
d'exploitation de la vulnérabilité
d'autrui de son corps une volonté de
destruction et que du coup cette volonté
là elle s'exerce d'autant plus
violemment et d'autant plus de façon
d'autant plus forte qu'elle s'exerce
dans un dans un lieu où c'est impensable
et où les personnes sont complètement à
disposition vulnérables surtout quand il
y a la possibilité soit d'avoir accès au
corps particulièrement l'intimité on
parlait de gynéco ou par exemple c'est
comme le chirurgien le squareg dans le
cadre de situation d'opération les
anesthésistes etc ou alors à 15 ans de
réclusion criminelle et qui est
actuellement mis en examen et plus de
300 victoires pour plus de 300 et ou
alors effectivement qui a accès à toute
une histoire à toute une intimité et on
sait que il y a un continuum de violence
qui sont subies et que beaucoup de
personnes qui vont consulter un
psychiatre on pense que c'est à peu près
70% des personnes ont un des antécédents
de violences particulièrement de
violence sexuelle donc ils vont parler
de ce qui leur est arrivé donc ils vont
livrer ce qui s'est passé ou de
traumatisme comme la situation de
confrontation à une mort violente dans
sa famille et du coup le psychiatre il a
tous les éléments tout ce qui tout ce
qu'il faut pour savoir comment agir
comment contrôler la personne comment
prendre l'ascendant sur elle normalement
bien entendu il est hors de question
d'utiliser cette cette capacité là de
compte de générer une emprise et de
contraintes la personne mais c'est un
espace où ça peut être fait mais c'est
d'autant plus grave que ça que ça soit
le cas alors que les personnes se
livrent et je voulais rajouter que le
soin est quelque chose d'essentiel pour
les victimes pour pouvoir
dénoncer l'effet pour pouvoir
se défendre et pour pouvoir aussi sortir
des énormes traumas que ça génère
et qu'à ce moment là elles viennent pour
être soignées et elles sont de nouveau
agressées donc là c'est quand même
enfin c'est d'une c'est d'une cruauté
particulière parmi les patients qui
frappent à votre porte y a-t-il beaucoup
de patients qui ont été victimes de
violence sexuelles par des médecins
alors j'ai un nombre important de
patientes qui ont été victimes beaucoup
aussi ont l'ont été
mineur et aussi dans le cadre de
l'institutions aussi de soins et
particulièrement les personnes en
situation de handicap qui sont vraiment
extrêmement exposées à des situations de
violence sexuelles d'autant plus dans le
cadre du soin et ça ça reste aussi un
tabou les institutions un tabou vraiment
très important on peut se poser beaucoup
de questions sur le rôle que joue
aujourd'hui l'ordre des médecins dans ce
qu'on appelle l'omerta autour de ce
sujet on va écouter le docteur
président du conseil national de l'ordre
des médecins que vous avez rencontré à
l'occasion de cette enquête en tant que
femme médecin je suis terriblement
impact par ces faits là
je lis la presse comme tout le monde et
quand je lis ces témoignages et
je suis horrifié bien sûr c'est
difficile d'envisager que quelqu'un de
s'incorporation puisse
violenter avoir
des attitudes inappropriées allant
jusqu'à la violence sexuelle et
le viol l'ordre des médecins est
particulièrement mis en cause dans votre
enquête elle est aussi mise en cause
c'est institution par un rapport de la
Cour des comptes qui a été publié en
décembre 2019 on en reparlera peut-être
juste après ça a été facile d'avoir la
parole de l'ordre des médecins vous avez
eu à la fois donc Marie-Pierre Gabiano
Ceccaldi et puis une année avant
Jean-Marcel Moore qui lui aussi était
vice-président de cet ordre des médecins
et vous êtes allé leur poser la question
de savoir mais que faites-vous pour les
victimes de ces violences sexuelles
ça a été difficile d'avoir une réponse
de la part de l'ordre des médecins pour
commencer en fait non pas vraiment c'est
c'est ma coralisatrice Julie Pichot qui
qui les a contactés après que on avait
ramassé un certain nombre de témoignages
si vous voulez et puis qu'on avait des
questions très précises à leur poser par
exemple sur le cas gynécologue dont on a
parlé qui est à Arras qui fait l'objet
de plusieurs dizaines de plaintes et qui
pourtant exerce toujours donc on avait
des choses très très précises à leur
demander et finalement ils ont accepté
de nous recevoir mais sans jamais
vouloir revenir sur aucun cas en fait
l'idée c'est à chaque fois été que mais
tout ça c'est du passé on est en train
de changer alors ce qui est assez
édifiant c'est que la première année
c'est le docteur Moore qui nous reçoit
vice-président de l'ordre et puis que
l'année d'après c'est une femme je pense
que quelque part ça veut dire qu'ils ont
compris que ils ont besoin de de de
changer un peu leur manière de
communiquer alors Marie-Pierre glavenwo
c'est qu'elle dit qu'on vient d'entendre
à déclarer l'omerta confaternelle ça
n'existe pas
or tout ce qu'on a vu dans votre film
prouve le contraire c'est pas
nécessairement ce que j'allais chercher
moi au tout départ c'est-à-dire en 2011
en 2012 quand je rencontre et puis filme
certains victimes
je n'ai même pas l'idée de ce qui va se
passer ensuite et donc je n'ai même pas
l'idée de ce qui se passe véritablement
dans les chambres disciplinaires des
conseils de l'ordre régionaux ou
nationales mais c'est ensuite quelque
chose que j'ai rencontré vu documenter
au fur et à mesure c'est-à-dire
quasiment toutes les tous les témoins me
racontent la même chose des assemblées
d'hommes très longtemps alors dit-on on
va changer les choses maintenant mais ce
sont des hommes il y a il y a un
magistrat qui est là mais ce sont des
médecins donc ce sont vraiment des pères
et alors ce sont effectivement des gens
qui protègent les leurs et qui sont
jamais du côté de jamais du côté de la
victime alors je veux que tout à l'heure
ce fameux rapport de la Cour des comptes
de décembre 2019 voilà ce que dis ce
rapport entre autres au cours des
dernières années plusieurs affaires
médiatisées relatives à des viols et
agressions sexuelles sur passion ayant
conduit à la condamnation pénale de
médecins n'ont pas été traités sur le
plan ordinal avec la rigueur nécessaire
entre 2014 et 2017
150 plaintes pour défaits à caractère
sexuel on était enregistrés dans les
chambres disciplinaires de première
instance ce qui représente en 2017
3,5% des plaintes près de 43% autrement
dit près de la moitié de ces plaintes on
fait l'objet d'un rejet de la part de
l'ordre des médecins
bon ça c'est le évidemment ça tout de
même
peser ce rapport ça fait parler de ces
violences sexuelles par les médecins
vous en êtes passé par là vous êtes
passé devant une une chambre
disciplinaire de l'ordre des médecins de
chambre départementale je crois comment
les choses sont-elles passées
comment a-t-il reçu votre témoignage et
quel a été leur conclusion vous
concernant je dirais qu'ils ne l'ont pas
reçu
je dirais qu'ils l'ont niait totalement
qui l'ont tourné dans le sens qui les a
rangés qui étaient en fait le charge
complètement en fait la décision qu'ils
ont rendu porte des jugements sur moi
sur mes écrits de
d'adolescentes sur sur des tas de qui
c'était moi en fait qui était qui était
sur la sellette et non pas non pas la
personne que j'incrimine très clairement
en plus il y a eu des choses vraiment
pas tellement normal parce que donc le
procureur a transmis le dossier au
Conseil de l'Ordre puisqu'il trouvait
que la personne que j'incriminais avec
eu un comportement qui a été quand même
un petit peu étrange puisque cette
personne disait qu'elle m'avait embrassé
sur la joue caresser le dos pris dans
les bras etc donc ils ont quand même
trouvé ça un petit peu étrange donc ils
ont transmis au Conseil de l'Ordre à
charge pour lui de faire quelque chose
effectivement l'ordre des médecins de la
Sarthe apporter plainte mais ils ne
m'ont pas demandé à moi si je souhaitais
porter plainte donc en fait ils m'ont
reçu comme ça que le témoin ce qui fait
j'ai pas eu tous les droits dans cette
affaire que j'aurais eu normalement en
étant en étant en portant plainte et
donc j'étais reçue comme simple témoin
donc j'avais pas accès aux arguments de
la partie adverse et je ne pouvais pas
rétorquer donc ça a été complètement
biaisé déjà ensuite au conseil régional
de l'ordre ils ont été corrects avec moi
d'un point de vue de comportement au
Conseil national en revanche pas du tout
je suis arrivée j'avais très très peur
comme le disait Xavier ce sont que des
hommes enfin en tout cas à l'époque ce
n'était que des hommes
âgés plutôt 70 ans que que qu'un autre
âge au moins et donc je suis arrivée je
les ai salués ils ne m'ont pas répondu
ça met quand même dans une perspective
assez difficile pour pour parler surtout
ne vous ont pas donné gain de cause et
tout allait dans le même sens finalement
de nier ma parole et de faire en sorte
que je ne puisse même pas m'exprimer
pendant l'audience puisque quand vous
dites pas bonjour à quelqu'un dans une
circonstance pareille c'est une façon de
le faire taire
vous êtes médecin quel regard vous
portez sur l'ordre des médecins après
avoir vu ce film entendu ce témoignage
et également celui de Xavier Deleu
je porte un regard critique
obligatoirement parce que là on a on a
quand même été confronté à une Sacha
bouge un petit peu faut quand même
reconnaître les choses c'est en train de
bouger mais à une position extrêmement
sexy dominante domination masculine et
de domination liées aussi un statut
enfin et à une reconnaissance entre père
et une absence totale de prise en compte
de la réalité de des violences de la
gravité de ces violences et de la
nécessité absolue de protéger les
victimes et on voit à quel point de
nombreuses affaires montrent
qu'il y a pas eu de protection qui a pas
eu de principe de précaution même tout
simplement faire de protéger le Conseil
de l'Ordre pour bien comprendre n'alerte
pas la justice lorsqu'ils ont eu une
alerte
du tout
signaler tous les faits qui vont être
portés à leur connaissance mais c'est
récent ils l'ont déjà dit il me semble
par le passé ça n'a pas été suivi des
faits donc moi je me méfie un peu de
leurs effets d'annonce aussi maintenant
je suis un peu et puis on voit que c'est
un milieu c'est un milieu dominant qui
du coup a bien véculé tous les
stéréotypes de culture du viol et de
remise en question des victimes etc les
victimes qui montaient qui racontaient
n'importe quoi etc et
de protection effectivement entre entre
père
de protection corporatiste mais ce qu'il
faut voir aussi dans le cadre de la de
tout ce qui est le milieu médical c'est
que c'est un milieu médical on commence
à dénoncer à quel point c'est un milieu
avec tout le côté Carabin qui était un
milieu qui véhiculé quand même du
harcèlement sexuel des violences
sexuelles et les différentes études qui
ont été faites récemment montrent que
c'est presque 50% des femmes étudiantes
en médecine étudiante en pharmacie qui
subissent des violences sexuelles
différentes formes de violence sexuelles
j'en ai moi-même subi en tant
qu'étudiante en médecine c'était
fréquent donc nous quand on était
étudiant en médecine on était agressé
dans un bloc opératoire etc
mon arrivée même pas à imaginer qui
puisse faire ça à des patients
d'ailleurs c'est déjà parce que en plus
on nous formater pour penser que c'était
certainement nous qui avions dû faire
parce qu'il fallait pour se protéger etc
et donc il y a eu tout ce climat là et
dernière chose et là le Conseil de
l'Ordre aussi il faudrait que vraiment
il y participe il n'y a pas de formation
des médecins sur très peu de formation
sur les violences sexuelles par Nord
pendant les études médicales et en
formation continue il y a pas de
formation sur les psychotromas les
victimes disent que le premier recours
quand elle subisse des violences
sexuelles c'est le médecin et c'est le
psychiatre ils ont pas formés et du coup
ne pas former ces médecins là c'est
aussi faire perdurer les choses et là
aussi le Conseil de l'Ordre il faut
qu'il diffuse aussi ces informations
faut qu'ils se mobilisent pour protéger
les personnes les plus vulnérables et
pas et pas les personnes qui sont en
position dominante
alors les une vertu ce rapport de la
Cour des comptes c'est que vous avez cru
y voir une référence à votre propre
affaire et à partir de là vous êtes mis
en tête de recenser en réalité
les violences sexuelles exercées par les
médecins et vous avez mis en place un
hashtag d'ailleurs qui s'appelle hashtag
violence sexuelle médecin 2000 personnes
ont suivi votre hashtag il est toujours
là il peut toujours venir accueillir
d'ailleurs des témoignages d'autres
victimes le fait d'avoir mis ce hashtag
en place d'avoir commencé à effectuer ce
recensement j'imagine d'une part que ça
a été catharsis pour vous et d'autre
part pour quel résultat est-ce que vous
avez eu le sentiment d'avoir libéré la
parole d'autres victimes d'autres femmes
certaines personnes sont venues à moi se
confier j'ai été assez choquée
d'ailleurs de voir que certaines
personnes étaient venues à moi qui
avaient été victime dans leur petit
enfant l'une d'un chirurgien et l'autre
d'un pédiatre donc voilà il y a aussi
des salariés de l'ordre des médecins qui
sont venus se confier pour des violences
psychologiques qu'elles avaient subies
de personnes de l'ordre des médecins
ensuite j'ai
identifié forcément une certaine ville
la ville du Mans où je viens à l'origine
et où sont passés les faits que je
dénonce et dans cette ville dans les
années récentes il y a pas moins de six
professionnels de santé qui ont été
inquiétés pour des violences sexuelles
sachant que c'est une ville qui compte
150 000 habitants donc je vous laisse
imaginer six professionnels de santé et
je me suis laissé dire qu'il y avait
d'autres noms qui circulaient donc voilà
on peut se demander comment une telle
chose est possible alors vous parliez
tout à l'heure des professions qui
étaient incriminées sur cette ville de
généralistes de psychiatre un
gynécologue pour des violences dites
plutôt gynécologiques et même un
pédiatre voilà donc ce lieu Deleu vous
vous la question que vous vous posez
c'est à quand un meet médecin finalement
oui c'est ce à quoi appelle ce
documentaire finalement c'est que c'est
c'est
alors on dit souvent la parole se libère
moi je veux vraiment je je je n'aime pas
cette expression parce que j'ai plutôt
le sentiment je fais la parole est
essentielle j'espère que je crois
qu'elle est accueillie je crois
qu'aujourd'hui elle est plus accueillie
mais elle est vraiment pendant des
années c'est pas que la liberté ce sont
les oreilles qui se débouchent en fait
voilà mais pendant des années les
micro-ondes se tendaient pas les caméras
ne se tendaient pas aujourd'hui les
mêmes rédacteurs en chef qui n'étaient
pas intéressé par cette thématique il
trouve aujourd'hui un intérêt mais la
vérité que c'était que c'était qu'en
fait les victimes étaient là elles
étaient prêtes à être écoutées elles
étaient prêtes à être entendues et c'est
la société et c'est les médias qui en
fait ne ne l'accordez pas d'intérêt
d'importance
j'ai noté que le le docteur Richard
poitevin qui était le mari de cette île
pointe donc elle-même était victime de
violences sexuelles par un médecin avait
consulté par exemple des sites comme
doctissimo pour essayer de voir s'il y
avait d'autres victimes de de ce même
médecin il a trouvé en réalité un une
réponse et ce qu'il faut évaluer les
médecins à travers des sites comme
celui-là
alerter être lancé d’alerte en tant que
que victime via ce type de site est-ce
que c'est une solution pour que la
parole soit encore plus forte du côté
des victimes écoutez moi je sais pas
quelle est la solution je pense qu'il
faut que la société de toute façon
avance la solution c'est à la fois des
des féministes colleuses qui mettent qui
qui écrivent tout simplement dans les
rues je te crois nous nous te croyons ça
ça fait partie de la solution c'est de
probablement de de de partager sur les
sur les Twitter sur des sur des Facebook
et en fait là où c'est essentiel en fait
c'est le documentaire le montre c'est
que une femme seule a très très peu de
chances de gagner ce qui est fondamental
et c'est pour ça que c'est aussi
fondamental d'être bien entouré c'est
difficile si on ne l'est pas c'est de
retrouver d'autres victimes parce que en
vérité
il y en a toujours et là c'est l'union
que tu fais la force c'est ce que c'est
ce que prouve aussi
les histoires de victimes et les
parcours de victimes que vous avez suivi
dans une vous allez avoir le mot de la
femme ce que je voulais dire c'est que
on voit à chaque fois que ce sont les
victimes qui font avancer les choses que
c'est elle qui s'exposent c'est elle qui
dénonce et elle qui avance
et qui remettent en question toute cette
culture du viol toute cette omerta tout
ce déni les phénomènes aussi de
prescription etc qui sont vraiment très
importants mais ce qu'il faut savoir
c'est que si on veut que les victimes
puissent reprendre confiance aussi dans
les médecins et qu'elle puisse parler il
faut que les médecins soient formés il
faut que ils dépistent ça y est
maintenant la Haute Autorité de Santé
recommande un dépistage systématique
faut poser des questions faut aller vers
les victimes faut pas attendre qu'elles
viennent alors elles finissent par
parler 10-15 ans à parler en moyenne le
plus souvent elles sont pas entendu mais
si elles peuvent être entendues et si
les professionnels de santé
reconnaissent la réalité sont formés
pour le faire sont obligés de faire des
signalements particulièrement quand il
s'agit de personnes de vulnérable et
comme c'est les personnes les
vulnérables qui sont les plus victimes
de violences sexuelles 80% des violences
sexuelles s'exerce sur les enfants et
puis les les enfants les personnes en
situation de handicap subissent trois
fois plus de violences sexuelles les
enfants jusqu'à 5 fois plus de violences
sexuelles quand ils sont quand ils ont
un handicap mental donc c'est poser des
questions il faut que tout le monde pose
des questions il faut que cette réalité
là elle soit plus tabou il faut il faut
qu'elle se sache pour que les victimes
soient entendues et que du coup les
agresseurs ceux qui sont en position
d'agresseur et qui profitent de la
situation qui sont là pour agresser ne
puissent plus le faire en toute impunité
parce que actuellement le problème c'est
l'impunité c'est moins 10% de plein de
pour viol
74% de classement sans suite moins de
moins de 10% de des 10% qui font l'objet
de jugement et au total c'est 0,6% de
des viols qui sont condamnés donc ça
c'est un vrai problème la lutte contre
l'impunité et elle passe par la
prescriptibilité et puis on va rappeler
Muriel Salmona que depuis 2002 et la loi
dite Kushner les médecins ne peuvent
plus pratiquer légalement un acte
médical je cite sans le consentement
libre et éclairé de la personne et se
consentement peut-être retiré à tout
moment oui et dans le cadre du
consentement sexuel en tout cas la
relation médecin malade il ne peut pas y
avoir de médecin patient il ne peut pas
y avoir de consentement éclairé libre il
ne pas être valide dans ce cadre-là
merci beaucoup à tous les trois devoir
participé à ce documentaire spécialement
Merci à VOUS Xavier Deleu et à Julie
Pichot qui a co-réalisé le documentaire
que nous avons eu l'occasion et le
plaisir de présenter dans cette émission
pour aborder ce sujet tabou que sont les
violences pratiquées par les médecins
dans le huis clos des cabinets médicaux
vos réactions ça sera sur hashtag débat
doc pour Twitter bien entendu nous
inviter seront là pour réagir à ce que
seront bien entendu ces réactions merci
à sel massali qui comme à la coutumée
m'a aidé à préparer cette émission et je
vous donne rendez-vous pour un prochain
débat doc et ça sera bien sûr avec son
documentaire et son débat à bientôt
[Musique]